what we're going to do in this video is
prove
that the limit as theta approaches zero
of sine
of theta over theta is equal to one so
let's start with a little bit of a
geometric or trigonometric construction
that i have here
so
this white circle this is a unit circle
let me label it as such so it has radius
unit
circle
so what does the length of this
salmon-colored line represent
well the height of this line would be
the y-coordinate of where this radius
intersects the unit circle and so by
definition by the unit circle definition
of trig functions the length of this
line is going to be sine
of theta
if we wanted to make sure that it also
worked for thetas that end up in the
fourth quadrant which will be useful we
can just ensure that it's the absolute
value of the sine of theta
now what about this blue line over here
can i express that in terms of a
trigonometric function
well let's think about it what would
tangent of theta b let me write it over
here tangent
of theta is equal to opposite
over adjacent
so if we look at this broader triangle
right over here this is our angle theta
in radians
this is the opposite side
the adjacent side down here this just
has length one remember this is a unit
circle so this just has length one so
the tangent of theta is the opposite
side the opposite side is equal to
the tangent of theta
and just like before this is going to be
a positive value for sitting here in the
first quadrant but i want things to work
in both the first and the fourth
quadrant for the sake of our proof so
i'm just going to put an absolute value
here so now that we've done that i'm
going to think about some triangles and
their respective areas
so first i'm going to draw a triangle
that sits in this wedge in this pi piece
this pie slice within the circle so i
can construct
this triangle
and so let's think about the area of
what i am shading in
right over here
what how can i express
that area
well it's a triangle we know that the
area of a triangle is one half base
times height we know the height is the
absolute value of the sine of theta and
we know that the base is equal to one so
the area here
is going to be equal to
one half
times our base which is one times our
height which is the absolute value of
the sine of theta i'll rewrite it over
here i can just rewrite that as the
absolute value of the sine of theta
over two
now let's think about the area of this
wedge that i am highlighting in this
yellow color
so what fraction of the entire circle is
this going to be
if i were to go all the way around the
circle it would be 2 pi radians so this
is
theta over two pipes of the entire
circle and we know the area of the
circle this is a unit circle it has
radius 1. so it would be times the area
of the circle which would be pi
times the radius squared the radius is 1
so it's just going to be times pi
and so the area of this wedge right over
here theta
over 2.
and if we wanted to make this work for
thetas in the fourth quadrant we could
just write an absolute value sign right
over there because we're talking about
positive area
and now let's think about this larger
triangle in this blue color
and this is pretty straightforward the
area here is going to be one-half times
base times height
so the area and once again this is this
entire area
that's going to be one-half times our
base which is one times our height which
is our absolute value of tangent of
theta
and so i can just write that down as the
absolute value of the tangent of theta
over two
now how would you compare the areas of
this pink or this salmon-colored
triangle which sits inside of this wedge
and how do you compare that area of the
wedge to the bigger triangle
well it's clear that the area of the
salmon triangle is less than or equal to
the area of the wedge and the area of
the wedge is less than or equal to the
area of the big blue triangle the wedge
includes the salmon triangle plus this
area right over here and then the blue
triangle includes the wedge plus it has
this area
right over here so i think you can feel
good visually that this statement right
over here is true and now i'm just going
to do a little bit of algebraic
manipulation let me multiply everything
by 2. so i can rewrite that the absolute
value
of sine of theta is less than or equal
to
the absolute value of theta
which is
less than or equal to
the absolute value of tangent of theta
and let's see actually instead of
writing the absolute value of tangent of
theta i'm going to rewrite that as the
absolute value
of sine of theta
over the absolute value of
cosine of theta that's going to be the
same thing as the absolute value of
tangent of theta and the reason why i
did that is we can now divide everything
by the absolute value of sine of theta
since we're dividing by a positive
quantity it's not going to change the
direction of the inequalities
so let's do that i'm going to divide
this by an absolute value of sine of
theta
i'm going to divide this by an absolute
value of the sine of theta and then i'm
going to divide this by an absolute
value of the sine of theta and what do i
get
well over here
i get a 1
and on the right hand side i get a 1
over the absolute value of cosine theta
these two
cancel out so the next step i'm going to
do is take the reciprocal of everything
and so when i take the reciprocal of
everything that actually will switch the
inequalities the reciprocal of 1 is
still going to be 1
but now since i'm taking the reciprocal
of this year it's going to be greater
than or equal to
the absolute value of
the sine of theta
over the absolute value of theta
and that's going to be greater than or
equal to
the reciprocal of one over the absolute
value of cosine of theta is the absolute
value of cosine
of theta we really just care about the
first and fourth quadrants you can think
about this theta approaching zero from
that direction or
from that direction there so that would
be the first and fourth quadrants so if
we're in the first quadrant and theta is
positive sine of theta is going to be
positive as well and if we're in the
fourth quadrant and theta's negative
well sine of theta is going to have the
same sign it's going to be negative as
well
and so these absolute value signs aren't
necessary in the first quadrant sine of
theta and theta are both positive
in the fourth quadrant they're both
negative but when you divide them you're
going to get a positive value so i can
erase those
if we're in the first or fourth quadrant
our x value is not negative and so
cosine of theta which is the x
coordinate on our unit circle is not
going to be negative and so we don't
need the absolute value signs over there
now we should pause a second because we
are actually almost done
we have just set up three functions you
could think of this as f of x is equal
to
you could view this as f of theta is
equal to 1 g of theta is equal to this
and h of theta is equal to that and over
the interval that we care about we could
say 4
negative pi over 2 is less than theta is
less than pi over 2 but over this
interval this is true for any theta over
which these functions are defined sine
of theta over theta is defined over this
interval except where theta is equal to
0. but since we're defined everywhere
else we can now find the limit
so what we can say is well by the
squeeze theorem or by the sandwich
theorem if this is true over the
interval then we also know that the
following is true and this we deserve a
little bit of a drum roll
the limit
as theta approaches zero of this
is going to be greater than or equal to
the limit
as theta approaches zero of this which
is the one that we care about sine of
theta over theta which is going to be
greater than or equal to the limit
as theta approaches zero of this
now this is clearly going to be just
equal to one
this is what we care about and this
what's the limit as theta approaches
zero of cosine of theta well cosine of 0
is just 1 and it's a continuous function
so this is just going to be 1.
so let's see this limit is going to be
less than or equal to 1 it's going to be
greater than or equal to 1. so this
must be
equal to 1
and we are done